in my latest book the authoritarian
moment i talk at length about how you
fight back against the fact that the
institutions of the united states pretty
much every major institution has been
hijacked by the left how do you fight
back against that and what i talk about
is the fact that the way the left
originally took control of institutions
is through a process that i call
renormalization it's not my term it's a
process that was originally termed by a
physicist named serge gallum his basic
idea is that with 20
of any organization you can reorient the
entire organization and the way you do
this is you create an intransigent
militant minority who's willing to take
incremental steps in pursuit of a larger
goal and then you pressure everybody
who's in the middle to basically cave to
you this is how institutions got
left-wing in the first place and at the
end of my book i talk about the fact
that we can re-renormalize i.e normalize
these institutions by using precisely
the same process lefted except in
reverse
you can unionize all of your friends
inside a particular company and say i'm
not going it's that critical race
training theory session we're not doing
any of that right you can organize all
of your friends and neighbors and say we
are not going to abide by this
particular mandate right this goes back
all the way to high school when you used
to say to your friends well they can't
suspend all of us right if we do this
they can't suspend everybody okay well
sometimes they could but sometimes they
couldn't well the reality is that when
people push back when liberty loving
people push back against predations from
institutions the institutions generally
are then faced with a transactional
choice cost right they have to determine
whether it is worth the while whether it
is worth the time and stress and money
of fighting that intransigent minority
or whether it's better to just go
weapons down
and as we are seeing in today's world
renormalization re-renormalization can
happen and southwest airlines is an
excellent example of this because
basically what happened is that a huge
number of employees at southwest
airlines said we are not going to abide
by your vaccine mandate and now
southwest has essentially caved
according to cnbc
southwest airlines has scrapped a plan
to put unvaccinated employees who have
applied for but haven't received a
religious or medical exemption on unpaid
leave as of a federal deadline in
december southwest airlines and american
airlines are among the carriers that are
federal contractors and subject to abide
in administration requirement that their
employees are vaccinated against covet
19 by december 8th unless they are
exempt for medical or religious reasons
rules for federal contractors are
stricter than those expected from the
biden administration for large companies
which allow for regular cova testing as
an alternative to vaccination executives
at both carriers in recent days have
tried to reassure employees about job
security under the mandate urging them
to apply for exemptions if they can't
get vaccinated for a medical reason or
for sincerely held religious belief
the airlines are expected to face more
questions about the mandate when they
report quarterly results on thursday
morning pilots labor unions have sought
to block the mandates or sought
alternatives such as regular testing
southwest senior vp of operations and
hospitality steve goldberg and julie
weber the vp and chief people officer
wrote to staff that if employees
requests for an exemption have not been
approved by december 8th they could
continue to work while following mask
and distancing guidelines until the
request has been reviewed
so basically what happened here is that
southwest looked at its bottom line they
said okay we're going to have to risk
running afoul of joe biden and the
federal vaccine mandates and maybe lose
some federal contracts or we can
continue to be cancelling thousands of
flights okay because remember the the
going line is that it was weather
problems that were causing southwest to
cancel a ton of flights and then it
turns out that american randomly had to
cancel a lot of flights you know who
doesn't have to cancel any of their
flights delta
because delta didn't do any of this
stuff
and so southwest has now essentially
backed down because what they basically
said is if you don't want to get the
vaccine apply for a religious
a religious exemption and if we don't
get back to you in time then we still
have these mass mandates that that we
are going to impose but
you know you can abide by those and we
will just continue to pay you and you
will continue to do your job because
we'd rather have you on the job than
have to suspend you without pay and then
maybe destroy our ability to even fly
these planes so it turns out that when
you get enough of your own employees to
resist what you are doing
that can have an immense effect on how
these companies are run
american airlines ceo doug parker spoke
with labor union leaders on thursday to
discuss vaccine exemptions american
airlines management indicated that
unlike the approach taken by united they
were exploring accommodations that would
allow employees to continue to work said
the association of professional flight
attendants that's the union that
represents all the flight attendants in
the cabins they failed to offer any
specifics as to what such accommodations
might look like at that time
choosing not to be vaccinated and not
receiving an exemption may still result
in termination said american it's not
planning voluntary leaves or early
retirement packages for those who choose
not to get vaccinated they say we want
all of our team members to be vaccinated
so they can continue working at american
we needed our entire team to run the
airline in 2022 and beyond and are not
looking to reduce head count
but when these companies are put up
against it and they have to choose
between whatever amount of money they're
making from the federal government and
their ability to literally put crews on
planes it makes it very difficult for
them to side with joe biden and you're
starting to see more and more businesses
do that right we announced that we were
not going to be complying with the joe
biden vaccine slash mask mandate
the the vaccine slash testing mandate
this is not something that we here at
daily wire we're going to abide by
because we felt this was a violation of
freedom of association and basic liberty
principles
and could not come from the federal
government well now we have a battle in
san francisco between the san francisco
department of public health and in-n-out
burger so in and out burger for those
who don't live on the west coast indones
burger is one of the biggest chains on
the west coast it is much beloved
and the in and out
establishment the the business
managers over in and out said we are not
going to be checking customer
vaccination documents we're not going to
check whether you have a covet vaccine
card before we serve you the san
francisco department of public health
therefore closed in and out on october
14th because employees were not properly
checking for customers vaccination
documentation the burger chain said in a
statement
the restaurant located in san
francisco's fisherman's wharf has now
reopened but indoor dining is
unavailable
in and outside it properly posted signs
of local vax requirements but refuses to
strictly enforce them
their chief legal and business officer
arne wenzinger said quote we refuse to
become the vaccination police for any
government we fiercely disagree with any
government dictat that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business
now this of course is a good and brave
and rational decision by in and out it
is simply ridiculous to turn all these
businesses into the vaccine police
that's absurd
using private industry
to cram down government bake the cake
policies is insane no matter what the
bake the cake policies happen to be
it's particularly insane coming from the
san francisco government where if you're
at the upper echelons you can unmask
because the spirit moves you as mayor
london breed once it suggested
so businesses are starting to resist and
this is good this is what stops all of
this and you're starting to see this
happen at the local level with regard to
police officers we talked about this
yesterday hundreds maybe thousands of
police officers across the country
are saying we would rather be kicked off
the force and then exceed to your
demands
and then we'll see how you like it when
you're the one picking up the phone and
having to respond to a 911 call where
all those social workers were talking
about hiring why you get those people
out there
chicago alderman brian hopkins he's
pointing out that chicago could lose a
thousand police officers over a vast
mandate that lori lightfoot herself you
know she she does not abide by any of
her own mask man it's again for for the
people at the top of the of the food
pyramid when it comes to
the government they just don't abide by
any of their own rules here is the
chicago alderman brian hopkins saying we
might lose a thousand police officers
over this
we're already short police officers
we're down you know probably about 20
percent
uh from where our peak staffing levels
were a few years ago so we're short
patrol officers where we've been
unsuccessful like jurisdictions all
across the country at recruiting young
people to choose careers in law
enforcement we have retirements
happening at an accelerated pace we
can't afford to lose a thousand police
officers we can't afford to fire a
thousand police officers over an impasse
like this right now
now what is amazing about all of this of
course is that democrats are going to
continue to push forward with this the
reason they're going to continue to push
forward with this is because when they
look at the polls what they see is that
most americans mostly or strongly
support vaccine or or indoor mass
mandates and all the rest okay here is
the thing the people who are most
motivated by things like vaccine
mandates are the people who are
resisting them
not the opposite remember an
intransigent minority can make a
difference here everybody who's already
vaxxed is already vast and so while they
may be okay with vaccine mandates
because they're already vast this is not
a motivating factor for them they're not
sitting around each and every day going
yeah man vaccine mandates that's what
we're for but there are a bunch of
people who are resisting the vaccine
mandates and for them this is the number
one issue
right this is something that we need to
understand about when you look at
political polling political polling is
taking your temperature on a particular
issue but one thing that it generally
does not do is ask you the fundamental
question which is where on the list of
issues does this rank so what you'll see
very often is polling support for things
that that are sort of broad left-wing
agenda items and then the left will say
everybody supports this right everybody
wants universal child care
and then when you ask people like on the
priority list where does this rank
people like 130th
right the people who who for the people
who are resisting a government mandate
in this particular case this is issue
number one if you're a business owner
and you're resisting a government vacs
mandate
then that is number one issue for you if
you're somebody who is kind of like yeah
vaccine mandates sound kind of good i
mean i've already vaccinated why
shouldn't everybody like that's number
10 issue for you
so what that means that the people who
are the most passionate can move
everybody else and that is what you are
seeing in real time it's going to have
real effects at cbs chicago reporting
yesterday
openly that businesses are just going to
stop moving to chicago because there's
not going to be any law enforcement when
you get rid of the cops because you're
saying it is more important for the cops
to be vaccinated than it is for there to
be cops to actually answer 911 calls why
would any business located in a city
like that
tonight an alert for businesses on
chicago's prime avenue our tara molina
is always investigating and joins us
live along the famed shopping street
tara this could stop some new companies
from moving into vacant storefronts
[Applause]
erica experts tell us there's already
that hesitation and it's not only
because of the continued robberies and
thefts here on the mag mile and across
the downtown area but because there's a
perception right now that chicago just
isn't a safe place to be
okay well that is correct and that's
happening in major cities all over the
country seattle police union president
has now slammed seattle's leaders
over these vast mandates mike solin he's
pointing out that seattle is going to
just lose all of its officers and then
we'll see how much they like these vacs
mandates
we've lost so many people because of the
political betrayal from our elected
officials in this city over 350 cops
gone
because we were once the modeled
reformed agency and then after floyd
these same politicians who invoked this
mandate
ran away from us as fast as they could
for political reasons now it's our
people are desperate to have their voice
heard
and this is strictly about the mandate
okay and he's right about all of this
okay resistance breeds the failure of
the authoritarian state people who
refuse to go along to get along are
going to be the people who end up
pushing back against the regulations in
such a way that liberty is preserved and
this is true on nearly every front now
what's amazing is that practically
speaking practically speaking
there's gonna come a point here where
everybody's just gonna have to let go
and the reason i say that is because
let's say that you even have a vast
mandate in place like israel right you
have these vast mandates in place
how do they even determine when things
are safe or not it's a real question so
it used to be that israel when you got
off the test they would do an antibody
test right they would check to see if
you had antibodies for covid and this
would be the way to determine whether
you need to quarantine or not and the
reason they were doing this is because
it is quite possible that you had two
shots of the vaccine and that it had
waned so did you need a booster or did
you not need a booster well now as it
turns out that's a really bad way of
determining whether or not you're immune
to the virus we've known this for a very
long time some of us have been saying
this for a long time that all these
antibody tests don't do bleep okay the
way you really need is to be testing t
cell and b cell immunity
right the memory cells that's what you
actually need to be testing which is
much more expensive and much more
difficult nobody wants to do that
okay so in the end what it's going to
come down to is just
how many infections there are how many
people are dying how many people are
hospitalized and when the numbers are
low everybody's going to be open about
it and when the numbers are high people
are going to start taking precautions
which is called risk assessment
and how we should have been dealing with
this since basically the beginning
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed